[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Marietta Slomka guten
Abend überraschend war der Schneefall ja
nicht die Wetterdienste hatten davor
ausdrücklich gewarnt aber vielen ging es
mit den Schneefällen wohl doch so
ähnlich wie mit Weihnachten das kommt ja
auch immer ganz plötzlich auf den
bayerischen Autobahnen gab es jedenfalls
lange Staus und auch auf den Landstraßen
seit gestern Abend hunderte Unfälle in
München fiel der Flugverkehr heute
komplett aus nachdem rekordmengen an
Schnee gefallen waren womit man in den
Landkreisen wohl unterschiedlich gut
klar kam wie Julian Schmidt verrent
berichtet ausgerüstet sind sie schon mal
im bayerischen Landkreis Regen sie
fräsen und Schaufeln sich durch einen
halben Meter Neuschnee in der Gegend kam
es bereits zu Stromausfällen und doch
sind hier schon fast mehrwege frei als
in der Landeshauptstadt am Münchner
Flughafen hebt bis morgen früh nichts
mehr ab mehr als 700 Flüge abgesagt die
Passagiere stecken im Terminal und in
Warteschleifen fest also ich will weinen
ich will auch schreien wäre jetzt aber
nicht ver nutzen weil es ist erstens
Zeit ich dafür auf habe das Geld und
dann steht man halt doch da wir haben
kein Hotel wir haben keinen Platz für
unser Gepäck wir können nichts tun das
ist unser Fall wir haben keine Flüge W
haben
nichts auch sonst ging es heute kaum
vorwärts Stau auf den Straßen und auch
auf den Gleisen in und um München die
Deutsche Bahn hat für heute den Betrieb
in der Stadt vollständig eingestellt
rechnet in Süddeutschland mit starken
Störungen bis
Montag se wgnisse werden auch häufiger
und H fehlt an der Vorbereitung an der
politischen Fokus dass die Deutsche Bahn
sich duuf konzentriert dass S es
hinkriegt auch dass sie ausreichend Geld
hat auch der finanzstarke Fußball ergibt
sich heute dem Wetter die Allianzarena
bleibt geschlossen die Münchner wechseln
derwal die Sportart wahlweise gleiten
Sie mit dem Schlitten durch den Schnee
oder dem Surfboard auf dem Münchner
Eisbach danach geht es für sie
wahrscheinlich wieder ab ins Warme
während die Flug Reis in im Terminal
eine weitere Nacht
improvisieren Klimaforscher weisen
darauf hin dass extrem Schneefall das
gleiche ist wie stark Regen nur halt im
Winter also zwei Seiten einer Medaille
ungewöhnliche Wetterlagen die im Zuge
des Klimawandels häufiger
auftreten dem Klimawandel bezeich fasst
sich befassen sich derzeit ja die
Teilnehmer der Weltklimakonferenz in
Dubai heute trat dort Bundeskanzler
Scholz auf er unterstützt den Aufruf aus
fossilen Energien auszusteigen die USA
und China wollen sich hier bislang zwar
nicht in dem Umfang festlegen wie die
Europäer allerdings ist China im Bereich
der erneuerbaren Energien inzwischen
einer der Weltmarktführer und legt da
ein bemerkenswertes Tempo vor Andreas
Stamm
berichtet ein Gigant versucht es im
Miniaturformat Chinas
Ausstellungspavillon auf der
Weltklimakonferenz putzig wirkt das hier
erneuerbare Energien als Kinderspielzeug
doch damit überrennen Firmen aus der
Volksrepublik gerade alle 80% der
Solarmodule 50% aller windkraftanlagen
sind made in China weltmarktüberflieger
in Sachen
Zukunftstechnologie wir sehen dass in so
gut wie allen Ländern heutzutage
erneuerbare Energien die billigste
Energiequelle sind insofern macht es
ztal Sinn rein wirtschaftlich darauf zu
setzen Deutschland war mal die Nummer
ein bei Wind und Solar könnte der
Kanzler denken jetzt wo sich 11 Länder
verpflichten bis 2030 dreimal so viel
Energie aus erneuerbaren zu gewinnen ein
großer Sprung nicht nur China dürfte es
freuen das Land dass das Dilemma der
Welt in sich vereint ökostromgigant und
mittlerweile größter Verschmutzer in
einem was aufhören muss mnt der Kanzler
zaghaft wir müssen jetzt alle die feste
Entschlossenheit an den taglegen aus den
fossilen Energieträgern
auszusteigen allererst aus der Kohle
dafür können wir bei dieser
Klimakonferenz die Segel setzen das
Schiff sollte längst im Hafen sein konte
an Umweltverbände die den Ausbau von
solar wind und Co begrüßen ansonsten
aber abwnken ich kann nicht fassen dass
der Kanzler davon spricht die
Erneuerbaren auszubauen und dann im
selben Atemzug verteidigt dass weiterhin
deutsche Steuergelder in den Ausbau der
fossilen Gasindustrie fließen soll neue
fossile gasprojekte egal ob in
Deutschland um oder im Senegal sind
nicht vereinbar mit dem 1,5° Ziel das
Ziel von
Dubai eine lasting Legacy so die Hymne
des internationalen klimakors hoffen auf
ein bleibendes Vermächtnis dieses
Gipfels Staats und Regierungschefs
reisen ab hatten ihren Auftritt jetzt
kommen die Unterhändler dran die es
richten müssen 10 Tage wenn sie ringen
um die Rettung der
Welt energiepolitisch Deutschland im
früher letzten Jahres wohl nur knapp
einer Katastrophe Entgang nach
Recherchen des Handelsplatz hatte Putin
vor die deutschlandtochter von Gasprom
aufzulösen und damit Deutschland den
Gashahn abzudrehen dank zweier
Informanten habe die Bundesregierung
davon gerade noch rechtzeitig Wind
bekommen stellte Gasprom Germania unter
staatliche Aufsicht und verhinderte
damit wohl den Zugriff das zeigt dass
der Kremmel in diesem Krieg auch auf
eigene wirtschaftliche Interessen keine
Rücksicht nimmt oder nehmen muss so
wenig wie auf das Leben der eigenen
Soldaten bei den Kämpfen im
ostukrainischen afdjevka ist Russland
bereit zigtausende zu opfern und auch
der Ukraine hohe Verluste aufzuzwingen
unser Reporter Tim Kröger ist dort nahe
der
Front was mikola und Viktor durchmachen
zeigt den ganzen Wahnsinn des russischen
angriffskriegs sie verteidigen die
schwer umkämpfte Stadt afdevka sie
werden durch einen Angriff aus der Luft
verletzt wegen der anhaltenden Kämpfe
können sie erst nach Stunden aus der
Kälte gerettet
werden es war ein Angriff mit Kamikaze
mit
Drohnen
ja sie greifen die ganze Zeit an wir
verlieren sehr viele Jungs man hat keine
Kraft mehr gegen sie zu
kämpfen sie beschießen uns mit
Artillerie und
drohka ist schon lange Frontstadt seit
Oktober aber rollt eine russische
Angriffswelle nach der nächsten auf die
Stadt zu um sie zu erobern die Verluste
auf russischer Seite sollen extrem hoch
sein und auch auf ukrainischer Seite
starben offenbar viele Soldaten
regelmäßig werden zum Teil schwer
verwundete zum sogenannten
stabilisierungspunkt hinter der Front
gebracht wo sie intensiver medizinisch
versorgt
werden es tut so weh das zu sehen
besonders wenn der verwundete der dort
liegt keine Beine mehr hat und fragt was
ist mit meinen deinen das ist sehr
schwer
manchmal können sie gar nicht mehr
helfen zwei Soldaten bringen einen toten
Kameraden der bei einem Raketenangriff
ums Leben kam Arzt Alexandre muss den
Tod bestätigen was wir aber nicht
filmen das ist der Ehemann Sohn oder
Vater von jemandem wir finden Briefe der
Familien Fotos der
Familien Fotos der Kinder der
Soldaten das ist sehr
traurigo
wie viele Soldatinnen und Soldaten ist
AR Alexandre seit bald Z Jahren im
Einsatz lediglich 10 Tage Urlaub hatte
er um seine Frau und seinen vierjährigen
Sohn zu
sehen er ist in einem so spannenden
Alter er fragt nach
allem nach
Dinosaurier kmos den
Planeten viele Fragen und ich bin nicht
bei
ih und ein Ende des Krieges ist nicht in
Sicht sobald sie geheilt sind kehren
wohl auch myikola und Viktor zurück an
die
Front und mit dem Blick auf den Nahen
Osten geht es jetzt bei dir weiter Hanna
die israelische Regierung hat die
Verhandlungen über eine erneute
Feuerpause im Gazastreifen abgebrochen
die Hamas habe sich mit Blick auf die
verschleppten Frauen und Kinder nicht an
ihren Teil der Vereinbarung gehalten
hieß es zugleich kündigte die
Terrororganisation ihrerseits an keine
Geiseln mehr freizulassen bis es einen
umfassenden Waffenstillstand gebe und
alle palästinensischen Gefangenen
freigelassen würden unterdessen gingen
an Tag 2 nach Ende der Feuerpause die
Kämpfe im Gazastreifen weiter dabei
bombardierte das israelische Militär
auch den Süden des Gebiets wo sich viele
geflüchtete Palästinenser aus dem Norden
aufhalten auch die Hamas setzte ihre
Griffe auf Israel
fort die Ampelkoalition sucht weiter
nach Lösungen um die milliardenlücken im
Haushalt 2024 zu schließen nun hat
Bundesfinanzminister Lindner erste
konkrete Sparvorschläge gemacht vor
allem in den Bereichen Soziales bei den
internationalen Finanzhilfen und bei
Förderprogrammen sieht Lindner
Möglichkeiten für Einsparungen das sagte
er der funkemediengruppe so kündigte
Lindner unter anderem an die geplante
der Erhöhung des Bürgergelds zu
überprüfen
anders äußerte sich spdchef Klingbeil er
erklärte dass man angesichts des
haushaltsurteils auch über Steuer
Erhöhungen reden
müsse die russische Polizei hat in der
vergangenen Nacht in mehreren
Homosexuellen Bars und Nachtclubs in
Moskau ratzien durchgeführt das
berichten mehrere russische Medien erst
am Donnerstag hatte der Oberste
Gerichtshof von Russland die lgbtq plus
Bewegung als extremistisch eingestuft
und in Russland verboten unter Präsident
Putin haben Repressionen gegen schwule
lesbische und andere Quere Menschen
massiv
zugenommen zum Fußball die deutsche U17
Nationalmannschaft hat bei der WM in
Indonesien den Weltmeistertitel geholt
im meters schießen besiegten die DFB
Junioren Frankreich mit
4:3 das Happy End nach einer emotionalen
Achterbahnfahrt der Dortmunder
parisbrunner bringt die DFB Auswahl nach
einer knappen halben Stunde per 11 Meter
in Führung in der zweiten Halbzeit
erhöht zunächst Deutschland auf 2:0
durch den früheren Freiburger Noah
darwig doch Frankreich nur 2 Minuten
später schon wieder mit dem
Anschlusstreffer durch Bua PR
Deutschland dann nach einer gelbroten
Karte für den Leipziger osave in
Unterzahl Frankreich kann daraus Kapital
schlagen amagu mit dem 2:2 es geht ins
Meter Schießen wo der Dortmunder
almogera ka den WM Triumph perfekt macht
mit wiständen zu kämpfen selbst schießen
wieder hinten zu liegen immer an sich zu
glauben das ist unglaublich dieser
wmtitel ist ein Hoffnungszeichen für den
zulzt so gebeutelten deutschen
Fußball vielleicht wirkt der Erfolg der
Junioren ja irgendwie inspirierend auf
die älteren Semester die DFB Spitze und
Bundestrainer Julian nagelsmann haben
sich heute erstmal durch die EM
Auslosung gezittert wie ker beobachtet
hatenhe das aus aber es hätte schlimmer
kommen können für die deutschen
anspruchsvolle Gruppe klar im Moment wir
sowieso jede hat großen Respekt von uns
gegenüber jedem Gegner wollen natürlich
in die nächste Runde kommen in der
Hamburger Elbphilharmonie wurde mit der
Gruppenauslosung feierlich zelebriert
was in knapp 6 Monaten für große
Emotionen hierzulande sorgen soll
beginnend mit dem Eröffnungsspiel in
Gruppe A sind die Deutschen als
Gastgeber gesetzt und als erstegner
zugelost ist Schottland das Spiel gegen
die deutsche Nationalmannschaft als
auftagt in die EM am 14 Juni ein
machbarer Gegner zum letzten Mal trafen
die deutschen 2015 auf die Schotten und
gewannen und über die EM Vorrunde kamen
sie noch nie hinaus das Eröffnungsspiel
gegen Schottland in München glaube ich
ist schon sehr emotional eine tolle
Mannschaft die emotionalen Fußball
spielt auf den Bundestrainer wartet viel
Arbeit für ein erfolgreicheres
abschneiden als bei den letzten drei
Turnieren in der Hamburger elfilarmonie
lockert der we das Maskottchen Albert
die Stimmung auf Albert rum und dann
fällt das Los als zweiter Gegner steht
der Name Ungarn fest das zweite
Vorrundenspiel für die Deutschen gegen
die ungarische Nationalmannschaft am 19
Juni Ungarn spielt ein sehr sehr guten
Fußball die haben ja eine ja sehr
stabile Bundesliga Spieler natürlich
auch mit mit schch premier leag Spieler
der extrem gut bei Standards ist für den
dritten Gegner fällt das Los auf die
Schweiz das abschließende Vorrundenspiel
dann am 23 zwei Duelle gegen die Schweiz
in den letzten 10 Jahren und zwei
Unentschieden die Schweiz klar sehr sehr
guter sehr sehr guter Gegner auf dem wir
uns sehr freuen die lose sind gezogen 24
Mannschaften spielen in sechs Gruppen um
den Titel ein halbes Jahr Zeit für die
deutschen um sich einzustellen auf die
vorrundeng Gegner der heimem Schottland
Ungarn und die Schweiz der EM Countdown
läuft zu den Lottozahlen an diesem
Samstag die lauten 10 24 29 35 36 47
Superzahl 4 alle Angaben wie immer ohne
Gewehr fehlt noch der Blick aufs
winterliche Wetter morgen ziehen letzte
Schneeschauer im Süden ab dann scheint
auf die Sonne im Norden und im Osten
sind Schneeschauer unterwegs im Westen
kommt am Nachmittag neuer Schnee auf bei
Temperaturen zwischen -4 und + 4° in den
nächsten Tagen wird es durch
gefrierenden Regen im Südwesten und in
der der Mitte gefährlich glatt
insbesondere am Montag und in der Nacht
auf Dienstag -4 bis +
7°. das war's von uns mehr zur EM
Auslosung und dem Erfolg der U17 gibt's
gleich im Sportstudio und ich melde mich
hier später noch mal mit den nächsten
Nachrichten gegen 0:25 Uhr Wiedersehen
[Musik]
tschüss